i would
work on in product design and and come
up with this new concept but then go to
customers
and see that customer were gaining true
value
and they they really seeing that we were
humanizing technology
and bringing back this experience to the
product team
and we were making things we were just
making
a customer more successful and we making
the world a better place by humanizing
technology i think that's why people
just
loved what they were doing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello welcome to 20 minute leaders today
i am with yaakov cohen the chairman and
ceo of harmony a driving force for
humanizing technology
by emphasizing devotion to core values
to enable a productive work environment
yaakov believes technology should work
for people rather than the other way
around
yaakov leads the product design
go-to-market strategy and company
strategy for harmony one of the most
successful software vendors in the
microsoft ecosystem with over 1500
subscription-based enterprise customers
97 retention rate and a consistently
profitable business
three years ago jakov led the management
by out transforming harmony into an
employee-owned company empowering every
single contributor to act as a company
owner
meet yaakov
yakov coin welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you excellent thank you for
having me michael
welcome i'm really excited for you to be
here and we're going to have a lot of
fun in these 20 minutes i love doing
these episodes with with all sorts of
different entrepreneurs you've been with
harmony as co-founder and today a ceo
and you were also chairman for i believe
almost 14 years is that correct 14 years
indeed yeah
in today's world it's very very hard for
me to find people that have been with
their tech company for 14 years so i'd
love to pick your brain on that and the
decision and you know really dedicating
so much of your time and i know that pre
in previous organizations you were part
of you also spent quite a significant
amount of time so obviously there's
there's a it's a personality thing and
you know before we get dive deep into
harmony tell me a little bit about
yourself yakov how do you get started in
the tech scene and sort of how do you
looking back how do you think through
your career
yeah actually i
had no inclination for a computer
programming at all
i love more
i grew up in france in paris and i love
the french literature
and philosophy
but my mom insisted that i need to be an
engineer
so yeah that's how i got to computer
science i i wanted to make dalia
and my parents was were vigorously
against it
they said i should stay in france
so we ended up
making a deal i will become a computer
engineer
and i will be able to make aliyah so
that's
that was a problem
just a computer engineer but you went to
the technion exactly for computer and
journey
right so what was that experience like
going from literature in france to going
and immersing yourself in engineering
it was brutal
i ended up making it okay i ended up
playing laude in computer
engineering but it was
such a cultural shock
to you and he required a lot of hard
work
and it took me a while to really find
myself in this high tech world
interesting now when you enter the high
tech world and you're studying
engineering what is your perspective
like how is it changing what do you
where do you see yourself integrating is
it as an engineer is it as a manager
yeah actually i really like uh because
of
that i really liked ideas
other than techniques and technology
so i've been always looking at how to
humanize technology
how can we
how can we take technology
and rather than getting really excited
about technology and programming and
i never got too excited about that
i ended up doing it because you know
that was the things i had to do but
i was looking for how can we change
human experiences with technology
give me some examples of how you
perceive humanizing technology in in
today's world just so that i i so that
we speak the same way yeah yeah sure
yeah so really what i mean by humanizing
technology is a lot of time when we use
technology you know in particular during
the pandemic with these zoom meetings
and with these whatsapps and these
and you switch from teams to zoom
and
you know it doesn't work
just frequently you know you all the
time are busy with technology
this feeling of
being overwhelmed
by technology you know too many apps too
many
too many things competing for your for
your attention
and i've been thriving to you know
technology is great it enables us to
connect remotely to do all kinds of
things
but
it should be done in a way which augment
our humanity rather than reducing our
humanity it should be done in a way
which
enabled me to concentrate and focus
rather than feeling all the time
distracted
now was this the
was this sort of the motivation with
harmony when you started is this is this
how it originated exactly exactly that
feeling that we had to harmonize and
that's how we came up with omni is to
say
how can we help
you know in the world of cloud how when
you have so many apps in the app economy
how can we help you know not the techies
but the the regular human being
which is not tech savvy the folks which
are in working in businesses in
enterprises which are looking at
technology as not as a mean to uh as a
mean to an end rather than a goal you
know
that's kind of my
always has been my attitude about
technology i don't get excited by
technology interesting
i see it as a mean to an end
to augment our ability to to be creative
to come together
and to and to make the world a better
place
so what is harmony in essence so with
harmony we we are a sas company
and we are focusing today on remote
working in the microsoft 365 environment
so we are really trying to humanize
the microsoft cloud
and while trying you know you got so
many apps like microsoft teams
and you got still points and one drive
and
outlook and we're trying to help the
regular
business user you know the common motels
to help them to cope with so many apps
so
we are
helping people cope with they need to be
in email to be connected with their
clients
but they need to be in teams
to be chatting internally and attend
meetings so you end up having two apps
two apps where you live into you know
usually people used to live in outlook
quite bad
so and now with teams and the pandemic
everybody is using teams or zoom
and or slack so you end up having
too many apps so
we're trying to bring all these apps
together
create a workplace which is more
with more harmony
so we we provide an outlook plugin which
brings teams
and sharepoint and onedrive in one place
and we provide a microsoft teams app
will enable you to really collaborate
with your team
and you bring emails from customers for
example and
crm records
so you can provide much better customer
service
tell me about the the decision
strategically to create a company that
is providing services
to
make to provide better user experience
for another company's products right so
here we have an example of a company
where you're saying well there's a
company here that has these products
that are being widely used we can become
experts in this and we can help others
have a better experience utilizing these
products am i correct
yes so we decided not to do our own
stack but actually to rely on microsoft
and the reason we did it is we it to be
very pragmatic
and it's not like we didn't raise a lot
of money to do it
and so rather than building everything
from scratch you got
hundreds of thousands of companies out
there which are anyway relying on office
365 right
so why not just helping these folks so
again i think this is the same approach
to to look at technology as a mean to an
end
and and coming up with a pragmatic
solution
which will enable business users all
over the world
to uh have a better relationship with
technology
right now how does this how does this
impact a growth of a company you know
whether it's internally whether it's you
know in terms of branding outside is
there any confusion and where this leads
to or what's happening you know in terms
of you know the the culture of of what
the vision of the company is
yeah to to a degree it's limiting in
terms of you know raising huge amount of
cash
but from um
it has worked extremely well for us
because we have today uh 1300 customers
and enterprise customers
uh we have more than 250 000 paying
users
um you know where we've been able to uh
a lot
yes and while i'd be profitable so
we have been able to to really engage
with
enterprise enterprises all around the
world
mostly in north america in
europe
folks like the the canadian government
e1
boss
and while really helping them to get
their job done you know to be able to
get a much better
experience in terms of personal
productivity but even more in terms of
collaboration
coming together
where's the personal the humanization
factor coming in if you're looking at
the
at the microsoft stack and i'm assuming
that we can just use microsoft as a
metaphor at this point because you were
talking about this idea of humanizing
you know a stack of technologies
regardless of who built them
where is sort of the the impact that
you've created with harmony when it
comes to to this suite of products that
people use
creating a unified workplace where you
have all your apps all your all your
content in one place
but and rather than having multiple apps
switching all the time from up to up
toggling across apps which which cause
um distractions rather than focus
right so having this ability within
teams for example
we bring emails
and
you can see
you can start chatting with all your
teams on a customer request
and you can you can
you know tomorrow we'll be able to see
the
the custom the customer linkedin profile
so i know what i'm talking about and i
can see the opportunity in salesforce in
order to be able to make
better team decision
so creating this unified workplace is
how we really harmonize technology
right
well what has it been like for you the
last 14 years so building a company you
know seeing it grow
becoming profitable getting to 250 000
customers what has that experience been
like for yakov
it has been a roller coaster it has been
an emotional roller coaster it has been
a lot of
failures as well as successes
um
you know the main thing also which has
been a really life-changing thing is
that
our vcs wanted to sell the companies the
vcs which owns the company you know that
they have this seven years
cycle yeah
and well late bloomers
so he didn't he didn't work within 87
years so as i said we want to serve the
company
and which was like totally legitimate
but but he didn't kind of work out and
when we wanted the
the employees and the management we
thought we were only at the beginning
how did you how okay so we're gonna get
to that in half a second but how did you
keep
how did you keep the leadership
energized enough you're saying that
you're late bloomers that it took it
took a while for it to jump how did you
get people to continue believing so much
and to to continue having that
conviction for so long
especially
that's a good question
and i'm not sure i know the answer i
think
you know faith and
is
so it's it's something which is
contaminating
contaminated right it's not a good world
these days
but when you believe
and and i've been a believer of what
we're doing
you know and the way i've been a
believer is you know i would work on in
product design and and come up with this
new concept but then go to customers
and see that customer were gaining true
value
and they they really seeing that we were
humanizing technology
and bringing back this experience to the
product team
and we were making things we were just
making
a customer more successful and we made
making the world a better place by
humanizing technology i think that's why
people just
loved what they were doing
i love it and
this this crazy idea of you know buying
out the company what was that about so
so as i said you know the the vcs and i
just saw that sequoia was
transforming the vc model to remove
these seven years window
yeah you get money from investors and
you need to return it within seven years
so you need to so just we were not ready
to we we tried to sell the company but
the company wasn't quite ready
so we decided to be the buyer
we decided you know what we love what
we're doing we want to continue to do
what we're doing and we also to our vcs
uh to to buy the company the only
problem we didn't have money and you
need money to buy a company so
we partnered with a misrati bank which
was very creative and very supportive
and we came up with a deal with the bank
where management would bring 25 of the
deal and the bank would loan 75 of the
deal
and and they you know rather rather than
the vc model it was like
a management buyout model with
traditional banking
wow
interesting they're very very creative i
haven't i haven't heard of many many
situations like they like these
and they are very successful because
they got
we returned and held on and they make a
nice profit on the loan but on top of
that they got one so they they own 15
percent of the company now
wow
and they just we we we just because we
are very profitable we distribute
dividends
and four million of dividends and they
were able to make um and next time money
on top of their loan retail so it was a
really win-win deal he was really
winning i love it i i just love those
creative deals now
take me back a little bit more take me
back to france you know before you make
aliyah before you join
the technion and
and you go into engineering you know
what are you really curious about you
mentioned literature a little bit what
what really like you know fascinates
your mind as a kid
i love the i love greetings
and
actually
i bought a christian bible because i
didn't like to go to the jewish school
wow and i i love the story of yourself
yourself exciting
and until now from a business standpoint
you know you look at the story of
yourself
his mother passed away when he was very
young he was a dreamer he was a dreamer
and and his his brother
were were more
they were walking the cattle
and they didn't like his dreams he had
dream of taking his ideas to the entire
world
and
he ended up being being almost killed
but then sold
and he never lost his face you know
despite the fact that he was betrayed by
his own brothers
his first startup you know when he was
working for putifa
he got betrayed by his pretty fast wife
and he was betrayed by the two folks
within the jail or pharaoh he never lost
faith
and he came up with his 14 years
business plan
to take
it to take egypt out of the mud
wow
i love it
and this persistence you know this
ability to
to see power to see
to not to to shape reality
rather than consuming reality you know
most people around there is the
consumerity and they got consumed by
reality
but actually we have the power to shape
i love it
if you look today
in your day today
where where to draw your inspiration
from you know both either you know
professionally personally you wake up
every day you're you're 14 years in
where do you continue to draw the
inspiration
actually i i read a lot of books and i
love the jewish literature and the bible
commentaries
and i found a lot of talents and i i
found
a lot of energy
in trying to really clap
to your super conscious
trying to go beyond your intellect
getting to the both above your intellect
and drawing
your energy from there
so that's what i found being very
inspiring
and actually you end up seeing also that
your colleagues
have a lot more to give that you may
have think initially
i love it
and what are a few words
if i were to ask your partners
and you know
where and your employees the vcs that
you worked with the mizrahi bank how
would they describe yahoo how would they
be relentless relentless entrepreneurs
entrepreneur
i can i can i can't obviously we didn't
touch on you know one percent of the
different things that you've experienced
in these 14 years going through the
journey i can only imagine the ups and
downs and i think one of the most
inspiring things that i that you know we
talked about in this call was
you know you mentioned that you were the
company was a late bloomer and you know
it sounds like some some partners didn't
fully grasp the potential or maybe they
lost sight of the potential along the
way in some capacity and but you didn't
as the relentless entrepreneur and
through great resilience and a lot of
creativity turned it around and and
today with 250 000 customers
paying off the loan and then some and
being highly profitable and i'm sure
that being also very very proud of the
long journey and not just of the product
you've built and so i think that for me
as young entrepreneur that's very very
inspiring
sunday is the beginning it's sunny is
the beginning we need to do a lot more
than what we have done so far
i love it
thank you very very much
continue the rest thank you take care
bye
you